>> MANGTANI: Okay. Before we get started--there's
going to be a few more people, they'll keep
coming, that's fine. So a quick introduction,
my name is Nitin Mangtani. I manage the enterprise
social team at Google. In today's talk we
were going to focus explicitly on Google Search
Appliance, which is our intranet search relation
which, you know, many of you are using it
or want to know more about the search appliance.
I also have two special guests with me today.
They'll be coming here later in the talk but
I just I want to--them to stand up and say
hi. And so, Chris and Robert if you guys don't
mind just saying hi. These are the special
guests which won the competition for the Google
Search Appliance Photo Contest. So they are
here to tell their story on how they are using
Google Search Appliance. So I'll invite them
to the stage at the later half of my presentation
and they'll talk about the use itself. And
so, thank you for coming. Without any further
ado, let me get started. So, you know, search
is something which is very near and dear to--to
us at Google. And, obviously, you all are
familiar with the consumer's side which is
Google.com and--there's a lot of innovation
that's happening on the consumer's side and
you've seen that search has become the de
facto starting point for all the information.
It's not just about finding documents and
news but it's about finding information related
to weather, finance, movies, and maps. It's
one single search box for all your information.
And the mission of the Google Search Appliance
team at Google--at Google is to bring that
same experience for enterprise. Now, we obviously
understand that inside the enterprise there's
still a lot of interesting challenges. But
there's no reason from an end user point of
view that you cannot deliver the same experience.
Quick update, and I want to thank all the
customers here. We do have more than 20,000
customers ranging from small to mix sides,
all the way to Fortune 500 customers, so I
do want to thank all the customers here who
have been using our products. The core mission
and, you know, the kind of the--the final
delivery that we are looking from, from an
end user point of view is this experience
and what we call a universal search. No matter
how varied the information is you might be
using SharePoint, you might be using Documentum,
FileNet, File Shares, SAP or any information
source out there. What do we want to deliver
is a universal search experience to the end
users so that they can go to one single search
box to get all their information. And this
is still kind of an ongoing problem; by no
means this problem is solved. And there are
a lot of interesting technical and organizational
challenges to deliver this vision. Today,
I'm going to talk about what Google is doing
in order for some of the tools and APIs we
have build to make this vision possible for
your enterprise. At Google we obviously eat
our own dog food and we've delivered this
vision to Googlers so that the Googlers can
go to one single place to find all the information
they are looking for. The four core areas
which--or you can think about these as four
pillars that we focus on to deliver that experience
are. The number one is user. What can you
do to customize the user experience? We obviously
deliver a default user experience but you
have a lot of APIs and tools to customize
the end user experience. And the secret source
for us is really the search quality. How good
the ranking of the search results is. The
second aspect is reach. Inside enterprise
there are a lot of challenges around. How
do you index for proprietary systems like
Documentum, FileNet, SharePoint, File Shares
and many of the repositories out there and
how do you do it in a secured way? So we have
done a lot of investment in building these
connectors and we also know the connector
framework so that you can write a connector
for it. The third area is security. And this
is an ongoing challenge because inside the
enterprise every document is secured and we
want to make sure we give the user all the
information, but all the information that
he or she is entitled to see. So I'm going
to talk about what does authentication and
authorization mean for search plans and what
you can you do from the customization part
of it. Last but not the least is scale. Once
you can index all these documents in a secured
way, you want to make sure you have a platform
that can index to one million documents, five
million, ten, twenty, so on and so forth so
that you are not limited by the indexing and
the scaling capacity. This is--this is again
an interesting aspect of the Google Search
Appliance. And inside the enterprise--this
is kind of a reality and you can do a better
job--is personalization. More likely or not
you know who the end user is and for the same
term the--the importance of the documents
varies. So, for example, if I'm doing a search
on SAML or security; if I'm in marketing,
more likely I'm looking for some road map
presentation or a datasheet. If I'm in sales,
I'm just looking for kind of a quick summary
of what SAML means. But if I'm in engineering,
more likely I'm looking for a design document.
And what we provide from a search appliance
point of view is this ability to configure
rules so that you can have different personas
and you can deliver a different search experience
based on who the users are. So, for example,
we have this notion of biasing controls. You
can create a different biasing policies based
on different personas. You can create a biasing
policy for everybody who's in marketing, a
biasing policy for everybody who's in engineering,
a biasing policy for everybody who is in sales.
And you can configure rules and say, if a
user is in engineering I want to give higher
importance to design documents. Or if a user
is in marketing, I want to give higher importance
to Roadmap presentations and datasheets. And
as you can see from the screenshots, it's
actually relatively easy to configure it.
We give you a simple admin-based UI so that
you can configure your policies and set it
up. And what you can do is you can set up
multiple policies base on these personas.
You can set up a policy base on URL or repositories.
You can set up a policy base on Meta data
or you can set up a policy base on date. You
can say, "I want to give a higher importance
for documents which are more current." This
is kind of going into a little bit more detail
on Meta data biasing. So, for example, you
know, in engineering there might be some authors
who are well-respected in their organization
or in marketing there might be certain people
who are writing a lot of important content.
So what you can do is you can create different
biasing policies and say, "You know what,
I want to give higher importance to all the
documents that were authored by John in the
engineering department or by Matthew in the
marketing department. So you can create these
different policies and so should these two
personas. Now, as far as the end user experience
itself is concerned, you have full control
on that also. What we do is we give you specific
results so that, you know, I go back to this
slide, you can definitely decide how these
links look like, and what the color of the
links is, how do the snippets looks like and
what kind of image you want to put for your
company and things like that. But more importantly
you can do more advanced customization. So
the top thing just shows you a small snippet
of HTML code. It's like an iFrame which you
can embed in any of your application. It can
be portal application or a Wiki or a standard
or an App and we deliver the search experience
for your users. But if you are an advanced
developer and you want to customize the entire
search experience, we'll also give you the
rest of it, an XML API where you can see at
the bottom of this, you can issue a simple
request to us with the actual query string
and the other parameters with the Search Appliance
support and in return we give you the XML
response. So to quickly show you the actual
place where you can look at it, we have a
complete protocol from how we return you the
results format. So if you look at the XML
output it gives you complete control on what
these search is also. It gives you the information
about attributes, what the Meta tags are,
what the format is, the cash link, the encoding,
you know, I can just go through the entire
XML, but the point I'm trying to say is that
you can get your results in an a raw format
which is XML. And then you can either Access
LP or any of the language to transform this
XML results into the HTML, render into your
portal or any available Wiki applications,
so kind of getting the best of both worlds.
If you want to take the default experience
that the Search Appliance provides, you can
take an HTML on IFrame. But you if you want
to write your own custom code and define your
own user interface, you want to have advanced
Meta data attributes and filtering and things
like that, you can use the XML API and it
gives you the Meta data attributes as well
as the search results with the snippets and
all the things that you see on the HTML IFrame.
So this is again, you know, the thing which
I always tell people, you don't need to remember
the links, just Google it. You'll get it.
Google Search Appliance search protocol will
give you the very first result which will
tell you where you can define your own search
interface and what does HTML XML protocol
looks like. So that's--that's kind of what
I, you know, focusing on the end user side,
allowing you to create not only rich UIs but
also more personalized UIs so that based on
who the user is, you can create different
experiences and you don't need to have one
single vanilla experience for your entire
enterprise. The second aspect which we are
focusing a lot is this notion of how do you
take the collective input from your employees?
This is kind of like crowd sourcing the search
information. The classic example I give is
that if somebody works for a [INDISTINCT]
they know where the vacation policy is, where
the travel policy is and where the official
documents related to your handbook and things
like that. If somebody is in sales, they know
where the pricelist is. If somebody is engineering,
they know where they keep the design documents.
What if you allowed the end users to submit
the search results back to the up lines? So,
you know, we have one of the popular features
called KeyMatch where an administrator can
set up saying, "For this query, this is the
best search result." But what if you take
the feature to the next level and open it
up to the entire enterprise so that you don't
have one person for the collective knowledge
of your entire organization so that somebody
in that [indistinct] can submit a link saying,
"For vacation policy, this is the best document."
Somebody in engineering can say, "For security,
this is the best document." So what do you
see on the top of the search results are these
results which are entered by your end users.
And once they have been submitted to the search
appliance, if somebody else does the same
search for vacation policy or design document,
they would see these search results on the
top. It will tell them who has entered it
and at the bottom you would see the search
results which are generated algorithmically
by the search appliance. Now, again, you can
customize the search enterprise completely.
So maybe the search results on the top, you
might want to keep on the right and say, "Search
results entered by employees or suggested
recommendations," and things like that. Think
about this as taking the social knowledge
that your employees have and kind of merging
with the algorithmically generated search
results that the GSA provides. The second
feature which has again required some customization
but is very popular, this is actually a real
screen shot from Google, you know, the Google's
intranet ware. If I'm looking for an employee
or something, I can start typing in the name
and it will give me auto completion for that
person. I can do the same thing for looking
up for conference rooms, or at the bottom
of it you could also see--we give you suggestions
for queries. So these are kind of similar
queries which somebody else had written. Now,
this entire experience is again customizable
and pluggable with the search appliance. What
we have done is there's actually a lab, so
if you go to--how many people are aware of
Enterprise Lab, Google Enterprise Labs? So,
you know, it looks like not many, so I'm going
to spend just a little bit time to explaining
this, what the Enterprise Labs is. So Labs
is kind of our delivery platform where we
can give you features before waiting for the
next release of the search appliance. The
analogy which I like to make is think about
Labs as big games. So if the search appliance
is like your Wii console--I like Wii a lot
but you can correlate it with any other console
out there. Think about Labs as those games
where you can download these games and plug
it into the Search Appliance. You don't need
to upgrade the Search Appliance to the next
release. You don't need to wait for the next
release to come because of this interesting
Lab; you can just plug it in. If you release
multiple Labs, and the specific one which
I was just talking about is called Search-as-you-type.
The entire Lab is available in open source
so you can download it. It's under Apache
2.0 Licensing. So it's a very flexible licensing.
And you can plug this thing, the Search-as-you-type,
into your own LDAP directory or an employee
look-up system or it can be an export system,
or it can be a glossary. It Google via linked
it into a glossary system, so if anybody is
interested to search for SAML, we can quickly
look up the glossary look-up and tell people
what SAML stands for or what GSA stands for.
So this is again a very powerful mechanism
which allows you to extend the search user
interface and allows users to quickly find
the information they are looking for. And
in some ways this is very similar to what
you see on Google, you know. On Google, I
can start typing in SAML or any of these things
that it'll show you the search goals that
you're looking for. The second point which
I was trying to emphasize--so, you know, we
kind of spend a lot of time on the end user
side because that's one area where we feel,
you know, it's part of the most important
area. Where we would, you know, people talk
about search. It's not about the performance
or scalability or other things. At the end
of the day it's how to deliver on the search
results software end user. And the search
experience is part of the deliverancy equation.
If you can deliver the right search experience,
your users can find the information that they're
looking for. And to me, that's the biggest
barometer for measuring if you have the right
search technology on it. The second idea is
reach. If you're not indexing all your content,
your users will obviously not be able to find
it. If you have, you know, 20 million documents
and if you're indexing only 5 million documents,
of course, your users cannot find the information
because you cannot index it. So, in some areas,
your search results are as good as your quality
of indexes and how complete/confident your
index is. At Google, we also think about,
you know, we try to think about what can we
do to make that problem easier. And so, one
other thing, which we have invested a lot,
is building connectors to different repositories
that are out there in the enterprise. Starting
from supporting different file formats. So
we support more than 200 different file formats
starting from Excel, PDF, Word, and others,
to all the way writing connectors to various
repositories such as Documentum, Share Point,
File Net and Livelink. Now, we do realize
that, you know, this is a pretty impressive
list, but it's not a complete list. I'm pretty
sure somebody in the audience has a repository
which is not there in this--on this presentation
here. So the question is, what can you do
if we don't support a specific system that
your organization has deployed. You have two
options; one is, we have a large partner network
which has built connectors to many systems
out there including Stellent, which is now
part of Oracle, Lotus Notes, SAP, Knowledge
Management Repository, and things like that.
But if you want to write your own connector,
it's actually not that difficult. If I go
back to my--the main information about connectors,
what we have done is the actual connector
framework itself. We have open source. It's
written in Java and it's completely open source,
and the four connectors that we have: Share
Point, Livelink, FileNet and Documentum are
also open source. So you can look at how we
build those connectors. And you can use this
connector framework, which is completely open
source. And I'm not going to go to their specific
detail, but perhaps the most important thing
here to look at the SPI of the connector interface.
It's literally easy to--the method that we
have used to expose these APIs is a traversal
method where you can traverse your back end
repository. Whether it's, you know, Stellent
or any proprietary repository and push the
information in the search appliance. And what
we have given you is not only this rich API,
which allows you to traverse your document
to more--other repositories. But also the
authentication and authorization APIs so that
you can write your custom security along with
the connector that you're being linked. And
finally, we give you an Admin UI so that you
can set up the schedules and say, "I want
to crawl my Stellent repository every two
hours or every twenty-four hours." So you
write that connector, you hook it up to the
search appliance and then you set it up in
your schedule. It's a pretty straightforward
exercise and depending on how complex the
repositories. It can take anywhere from a
week to maybe two weeks. And both the connector
framework as well as the connectors themselves,
everything is open source under Apache 2.0.
So, you're welcome to look at the code and
you're also welcome to customize any of the
connectors that we have. [pause] This is kind
of giving you a little bit more technical
depth of this connector framework. At the
very high level, you can think about--you
know, there's the search appliance which has
all these API hooks to push the documents
inside the search appliance. But then the
connector framework itself is a container-based
application which you can deploy it at any
servlet end unit as is done in Java. And the
container gives you these APIs, the SPIs which
are implementing your own connector and deploying
with it. And finally, the--you know, most
likely, you would end up using some library
from your actual repository unless your backend
repository supports web services. In that
case, you don't need to have any native Library
to talk to your backend system. So for example,
in the case of SharePoint, we use web services
to directly talk to SharePoint to retrieve
the information. In case of document, I mean,
labeling, we use the LAPI API or the DCTM
API to talk to those repositories to fetch
all the document. The important thing about
this is it's not just documents. You can also
retrieve Meta data, which is associated with
your document as well as the security. So
you're literally taking the entire structure
that you have created in your bank-end repository
and pushing it into the search appliance so
that you can get the same native search that
your backend system will give but much better
search quality in the ranking and you can
leverage the search appliance features. The
second aspect of reach is--and this is very
important, is--it's not just about documents.
Documents are definitely very important and
search is in some ways associated with documents.
But if you look at what we've done on Google,
you can not only search for documents but
also for structured information. You can do
a search on weather. So, you know, a very
simple example which I always tell people
is you can do--go to Google and do a search
on weather in Mountain View. The very first
result that you'd see here is actually the
weather--it's the Real Time weather information.
And we're not indexing this weather information.
It doesn't make sense for us to index the
actual weather, which is in a specific zip
code. We're doing a Real-Time call to a weather
service. The same concept applies inside the
enterprise. We have a lot of business applications,
for example, your URP system or your BI system.
But it doesn't make sense for the search appliance
to go and index this information. But we still
want to make it easier for your end users
so that they can go to one single search box
and enter a query, purchase order, 500 or
East Coast sales or support ticket 385. And
what we're doing is we are giving you this
framework where you can make real time call
into your backend application based from these
triggers. So this is kind of going a little
bit more detail on how the logic works. So,
you know, from an end user point of view,
user enters a query, for example, purchase
order, $500 or East Coast sales. You as an
administrator would have set up several triggers.
You can set up a trigger for words like purchase
order, sales, support ticket, contact, and
things like that. What it means that for each
trigger, you are associating a backend URL,
which is like a rails base URL and saying,
"If somebody is entering a query purchase
order, I want to invoke so and so API from
your backend system." You make that rails
base call to your backend system. The actual
provider renders the search results back to
us in a specific XML format that we have given
to you and they give the search results back
to it. And finally, what you see is that the
search result that we get from this one box
is displayed as the very first result on the
top of all your search results. And this can
theoretically be any application that you
have. The API is flexible enough to talk to
any of the applications that you have. And
the good news is a lot of our partners, like
Sales Force, have already return this predefined
OneBox modules. So all you need to do is just
configure that OneBox module and associate
it with a trigger. You don't need to write
any code for it. But, you know, I can understand
there might be ten, fifteen applications,
which there aren't any OneBox modules. So
the actual code for writing this is relatively
easy. This is kind of the administrative side
of it where you set up these triggers and
then you configure the providers. The actual
providers itself can be written in any language.
It basically supports the rest of this protocol.
It takes the query in the authentication request
and then they respond. This is like a quick
snapshot of the XML schema. You just need
to give us the URL, the provider of the search
from the title you want to display in the
image and any other information and we'll
take your rendering code and plug the search
result back into the standard search results
that we are defining. So, you know, again,
a very powerful feature but literally easy
to set it up and display and integrate. Just
a quick show of hands, how many people have
actually played with OneBox or deployed it?
That's not bad. Around 20% people have used
the search appliance OneBox already. Let's
see. So I think we covered two of the most
important areas. One is the end user experience
which is model customizations that you can
do from an end user search experience point
of view and the second is the reach. How you
can index content and how you can invoke backend
systems from your business application. The
third aspect is security. What we do is--this
kind of slide gives you a quick snapshot of
all the security protocols that we support
starting from basic protocols like HTTP Basic,
NTLM, and LDAP, as well as advanced protocols
like Kerberos integrating with your sign-on
systems like SiteMinder and Oblix, as well
Certificate-based. But there might be guesses
where you want to do your own custom security.
You might be using a database for authentication
or your authorization rules are stored in
a proprietary repository which doesn't fall
into any of these buckets. So what we support
to write your own custom authentication authorization
code is SAML SPI. And SAML is the standard,
it's not Google proprietary. It's always a
standard which you can write your own SAML
cord both for authentication and authorization.
You plug in that SAML providers in the search
appliance. And what we do is we do a callback
when a user is trying to issue a query and
we ask you a question to the SAML provider
that you use, does this user has the right
credentials. And then once he's authenticated,
we also involve the authorization module to
ask the SAML provider a question saying, "This
user is trying to access these 20 documents.
Does he or she have access to those documents?"
So you get to use the 98% of the search appliance
capability. But for security, you can write
your own custom authentication authorization
and we'll make callbacks to your module as
the users are trying to find information and
do secured searches. This has kind of goes
a little bit more in detail to kind of quickly
walk you through some of the steps on how
to--the default security works. The user does
have security and you have an option where
you can set up a flag which says, access equal
to A, which is he's doing a secured search.
The second thing we do is we ask him or her--their
credentials. If they're using Kerberos, we
can directly look up at the silent authentication
that they get. We make sure that the authentication
is done using your backend system. Once we
have the authentication token, we get all
the search results that match their particular
query. There might be 50 search results which
match their query security or design document.
Now, we don't want to go and check authorization
request for all 50 of them because in most
likelihood we'll just return the first 10
or 15. So we go back to your backend system
and make a head request and check if that
user has access to those documents or not.
And if he or she has access to those results,
we put it back in the search result, but if
they don't have it, we silently take that
search result out of the final search delivery.
Now, the same module applies when you're writing
your own custom code. Instead of, we talking
to your back end systems directly, we'll talk
to your SAML authorization provider and ask
that same question saying, "John is trying
to access these URLs, does he or she has access
to it?" So those are kind of two things you
can do. You can either use the default security,
which we have in the search appliance or you
can write your own SAML authorization. And
again, this is very well explained. If you
go to the search appliance authentication
documentation, there's also some sample and
stuff. You can look at both the authentication
and the authorization SPIs, and it walks you
through the standard details on how you can
use SAML to write your own redirect protocol.
Now, SAML is obviously, it has its own kind
of artifact binding protocol on how the redirection
works with authentication, so we are implementing
that very same protocol. This just gives you
a little bit details on how you will bind
those URL's in the search appliance and associate
it saying, what SAML use so and so artifact
binding and--for authorization use so and
so URL. So this documentation kind of goes
into a little bit more detail on the protocol
and the actual analogs that you'll have to
implement. How many people are familiar with
SAML or played with SAML here? How many people
have actually deployed something on SAML?
Okay, very few. So, you know, I think it's
also a feedback to us to perhaps; we need
to reduce some of the complexity and the barrier
on these protocols to make it easier or make
a little bit of more sample codes so that
you guys can looks at it then and play with
it. It's actually not that difficult to write
your own SAML model. And the flexibility that
it gives you is really powerful because it
allows you to write complete custom code for
your authentication or authorization. So,
I think I have another 10 minutes or so. Just
from kind of logistics point of view, we try
to give the Q&A at the end. I hope that's
okay with you guys so that we can spend the
last 10 or 15 just on the Q&A side of it.
And so, if you have any questions on APIs
or the Search Appliance, we'll go through
it. So I have a few more slides. I just want
to go over it in a little bit detail before
we switch over to the two guests we have here,
and then open it for Q&A. The last three day--which
I'll only emphasize a little bit. And this
is again the unfortunate reality of some of
the enterprise search deployments out there.
If you have the scale to 5 or 10 million documents,
more likely your search deployment is going
to look something like that. And if any one
who has deployed search to a higher scale,
they'll realize that how many systems you
need to set it up and what kind of complexity
it entails to a human scale to 10 million
documents. We believe this is--this is not
needed. You know, we can make things much
simpler. You don't need to worry about indexing
and serving and crawling in all that stuff,
it should be hidden from you. And I think
the fine balance that we are trying to play
here is that we want to give you a plug and
play box but at the same time, as I mentioned,
you know, throughout my presentation, it's
not a blog box. You have APIs to write your
own user interface. You have APIs to index
whatever you want to index along with whatever
Meta data you have. Your APIs should write
your own custom code. So simplicity doesn't
mean lack of functionality. I want to insert
to--this is if you want to index 10 million
documents. This is our answer. And literally,
it requires one single search box and those
of you who are using it can testify at how
easy is it to plug and play. Now, you know,
sometimes we got a criticism from some of
our friends that it's great to have this simple
model, but it's not flexible enough. And the--our
answer is really what I explained to you today
in the slides is that you can get the best
of both worlds. You can get a simple box which
is easy to plug and play, but at the same
time we're not stopping you to customize your
box. The APIs allow you to practically do
everything what you would do with the traditional
deployment like this. All right, and our point
is you don't need to worry about such a complex
deployment to get the rich customizations
in the APIs. And, you know, if you look at
the trajectory of--and this is just and I'm
going to quickly show you, you know, how rich
you have built some of these APIs. I mean,
starting from the entire Connector Manager
or Connector Framework which gives you complete
control on your indexing capabilities. We
have the open source to Framework, the APIs
that are available. If you go more further
on to authentication and authorization again,
these are standard protocols SAML which you
can customize it. You don't need to worry
about writing any propriety code. OneBox--again,
simple rails base protocol, you don't need
to implement complex soft marshalling on it
and another thing it's very easy to implement.
You can tie to any backend business application
to finally the actual search protocol, to
customizing your search interface itself.
You can either take your HTML IFrame and plug
it into your portal or you can write your
custom XML code to use XSLT or other formats
to customize your search. So, you know, I'm
trying to give you the spectrum here on how
rich the APIs are and, you know, how much
you can do with the Search Appliance. And
at the same time we are delivering you a simple
model, and so, from a deployment point of
view, you don't need to worry about how do
you set this up in your data center. You literally
take this one. And I have set of couple of
Search Appliances, and it took me less than
half and hour to plug it up, put it in and
eject and start crawling their content. And
so, if you want something basic and up and
running, you can get it up and run it within
hours. If you want to customize it, it's absolutely
possible. We want to reduce the barrier on
how you can customize it and how easy and
simple those customizations are. So, you know,
I think we're doing good on time. And I don't
want to--what I'm going to do is I'm going
to switch gears a little bit and invite WellStar
here. WellStar is one of the winners of--we
had this competition for, you know, the Search
Appliance, how does it look like before the
shoot. So, WellStar is one of the winners.
And I'm glad we have the representation from
WellStar to come in and talk about the solution.
So why don't I invite Robin here. And why
don't we give him a big round of--thanks to
them for coming here. Thank you.
>> ROBIN: Thank you. Good afternoon everybody.
First of all, I'd like to thank Google for
sponsoring the winners of GSA Photo Story
contest. We had a great time creating the
photo with Dr. William Cooper, the medical
director of cardiovascular surgery at Kennestone
Hospital in Atlanta. You can see him in the
back looking very surgical. I'd also like
to thank our lead developer, Joseph Ramos
and Web Developer, Ralph Mallebranche, both
in the back for participating in the photo
and then subsequently finding out that we
did ended win and refusing to come up here
with me.
>> MANGTANI: [laugh]
>> ROBIN: So, you know, thank you guys very
much. The GSA is obviously an incredible asset
to healthcare. But I believe its healthcare
specific APIs are relatively scarce. So what
I'd like to do today is present some "API
in the sky ideas" to everyone and get the
GSA development community talking about poor
profit scale innovation and the not for profit
sector. The question is what makes this interesting?
And the answer is a little bit touchy-feely.
At the end of every IT system that we support,
there is a patient, and generally, an immediate
family who is incredibly concerned about that
individual's well-being. That's the touchy-feely
side. On the business side, there is an extended
set of friends and relatives who are all potential
customers on the periphery of each patient
relationship. This socio-business structure
of referrals and interconnectivity is what
we call the health find. And, you know, healthcare
as an industry kind of enjoys the unique situation
of shared need among all the individuals involved.
And the goal is to provide such superior care
and service that you're naturally earning
business before, you know, a patient is biologically
forced to take it to a competitor. The funnel
for gain in this business from the health
find is generally technology based. And in
many ways, it tapers in from efficiency, which
is a where the GSA excels. So I'd like to
show you two examples of how our WellStar
Web team has thought about using the GSA to
tie everything together on our internet. The
first example is a search engine result page
that mirrors the structure of our health system
and categorizes information in a useful way.
At the top, we placed our five hospitals,
two administration buildings, and the system
warehouse which makes facility specific searching
obviously easy. We've also placed a file,
a file-type drill down on the right hand side,
so employees can immediately narrow the results
if they know an item is in the common format.
But what would really make this interesting
is a hospital census and a Google Chart in
API that publishes Real Time data for managerial
interpretation. In many ways, a hospital is
a lot like a hotel. As your amount of patients
increase, you need to staff adequately to
provide great service. By supplying administrators
with the study stream of department-specific
data, ambulatory services can actually be
rerouted to more effective locations during
peak capacity scenarios. The GSA effectively
becomes a one-stop shop for current operating
data.
>> MANGTANI: So this is the OneBox or what
features are the...?
>> ROBIN: That would be the OneBox.
>> MANGTANI: That would be the OneBox.
>> ROBIN: Yeah, these are all concepts that
we'd like to--that we'd like to see on the
GSA development community work on because
there's not enough people out there looking
at healthcare in ways that we can do some
stuff here. The second slide is a Health 2.0
slide. I know that, you know, in, I guess,
kind of, you know, the world of Google here,
everybody is pretty much sick of hearing Web
2.0. Well, this is just hitting hospitals.
So, the second example uses a double exclamation
point MD Trigger at the top which you talked
about earlier, to return to specific style
of physician listing. This includes popular
Web 2.0 components, a valuable location-based
service that eliminates physician paging and
a stylized result page. By utilizing the Trigger,
employees retain their traditional Google
Search while gaining the unique functionality
of a feature-rich physician listing. Cycling
between the listing and traditional results
is as easy as removing the Trigger or clicking
one of the drilled down options. The informational
value on a page like this is immense. By integrating
the Google Maps API with WellStar's RFID badge
system, the clich, that nasal announcement
of paging doctor so and so is finally retired
to television drama as a physician is traced
though the specific buildings on our campus,
Google's API can pick up the bigger picture.
Our clinical staff includes some incredible
constant authors who are involved with system-produced
multimedia. And this page also features their
latest work. There should be a photo up in
the right hand corner there, but there's none.
It would be some type of media, some video
or something produced by one of our physicians.
For example, if you have another outbreak
of swine flu or something like that, you have
a physician go on and produce a media and
can post it immediately for distribution.
It's a very comprehensive overview of each
clinical contributor. So, here we can see
the white text and white background there.
We employ--our WellStar health system employs
over 12,000 people who not only work there
but also live in the service communities.
Your own city can benefit from this type of
connectivity, and it's full of patients, employees,
friends and families who can all benefit from
a healthcare center of APIs that you develop
with the GSA. And doesn't that type of opportunity
just make you warm and fuzzy?
>> MANGTANI: It's pretty good. That's a pretty
impressive mode of customization you guys
are thinking about and have done.
>> ROBIN: Yeah, absolutely. You know, with
the badge system, especially the paging idea
would be--would be great for surgery.
>> MANGTANI: Now, how many developers do you
have working on this?
>> ROBIN: There are three of us.
>> MANGTANI: That's--that's a lot.
>> ROBIN: You think so?
>> MANGTANI: No, that's--that's really good.
Well the customization is very rich.
>> ROBIN: Yeah, absolutely. And that's one
of the things that we loved about the GSA-2
is that we kind of pop it in there and then
went to work. I think the ratio that was often
quoted was that it takes, you know, 0.1. Developers
to actually implement in and use it.
>> MANGTANI: Yeah, no, this is--this is very--I
mean, I'm actually pleased to see some of
the customization you guys are doing or all
of you've done. I mean this looks like--it
looks like the universal search for healthcare.
>> ROBIN: Sure.
>> MANGTANI: Like one single place for all
your information for your...
>> ROBIN: Absolutely.
>> MANGTANI: For your patient and for everything.
That's--that's really awesome. I need to be
a WellStar customer, I guess.
>> ROBIN: Yeah.
>> MANGTANI: In a nice way without getting
sick. Without getting sick can I be your customers,
and so. Well, thank you so much and congratulations
once again.
>> ROBIN: Thank you.
>> MANGTANI: So, I would like to invite one
more guest from the State of Missouri. And
they are also winners of the photo contest.
So Jim, thank you for coming and please give
a round of claps for Jim for coming. You want
me to hold it?
>> JIM: Yeah, no, it's good. Yeah, I'm with
the State of Missouri. It's a little bit different
for us, my presentation and my story that
I sent in. We indexed the content for state
government contact that faces the public side.
And so, we don't necessarily look inward to
our intranet but outward and give the citizens
of the State of Missouri in any businesses
that they want to do business with the State
of Missouri a way to find information. So,
I thought I'd tell you a little bit about
what where we were, and then where we are,
and then kind of the future where we want
to go. Missouri is set up as 16 executive
agencies and then there are those various
other agencies and boards and commissions
along with that, but each of those agencies
was basically a silo. They had their own IT
staff, their own Web developers, and their
own application developers. There was no commonality;
no common web search was implemented throughout
any of there. And there was really no unified
way of doing a search across our executive
agencies when it was very likely that if you
wanted to do business with the State of Missouri,
you may need to go to the Department of Natural
Resources as well as the Department of Agriculture.
And those two sites were completely different.
Where is Missouri? A few years ago, about
the same time, we--several things happened.
First thing was we purchased Google GSA. And
I can testify that it is just as easy as he
says it is to plug it in.
>> MANGTANI: That looks pretty good on your
data center. Very noticeable.
>> JIM: Yeah, it is. It is very noticeable;
it stands out, but very easy. And so, we purchased
the Google GSAs and about the same time, we
also had a major IT consolidation within state
government. All those 16 agencies that had
IT staff, all of a sudden, one day became
one organization, one IT organization. So
now, we had control of all of the developers,
all of the Web developers, all of the IT staff
worked for one organization now that supported
those 16 agencies. And so now, all of our
government content is indexed. All of the
public facing government content is indexed
and available to the citizens in a uniform
manner across--across government. It provides
for much richer search. We feel confident
that we're providing all that information
out. The reach that he talked about, we--we've
got that now and we can--we're confident when
a business wants to do business with the State
of Missouri, that when they come to our State
homepage or any other of those agencies, they
really get what they wanted to find. And I've
wrote, the bottom line, basically, is now
we--we are able to provide reliable information
out to customers and citizens. The future,
we got a new administration, just like every
state does. We swore that new administration
in, in January. And with that swearing in,
we got a new position in state government
in the in CIO's office, with was the deputy
CIO in-charge of Web presence. And that person
is specifically going to focus on the Web
for state government. They have a lot of plans
for state government. They want--this soloist--that
person's sole focus isn't how we present ourselves
out to the Web. You know, Web 2.0 is just
now maybe hitting the medical field. Well,
the government field is even further behind.
And so, it's good that we now have somebody
who's focused on how do we use those technologies
and those tools that are out there to help
citizens do business with us. The vision that
the deputy CIO has is for the website of state
government if represented on a user standpoint
rather than how government wants to present.
Me, as a government employee, I mean I know
exactly where to go to find what I want. But
you as a person moving to Missouri or a business
trying to do business with Missouri have no
idea how government is structured. Eventually,
we want to get to where users can select what
data they want to see on their website. We
want to increase the use of the OneBox. We've
started to, I think, investigate that. And
really, the goal--and Google really helps
us go in this direction as a government entity.
We want to be as transparent with the tax
dollars as we can. We want to give the citizens
access to all the information that they've
basically paid for. And Google has provided
that ability already. And then we're--we really
want to take that further and start utilizing
not only web OneBox but the Web services to
query Real Time data. And in there, there
has been talk now of internally facing the
Google Appliance so that we can search our
intranet and make our internal employees even
more efficient. So that's really all.
>> MANGTANI: Chris, thank you so much for
coming here and sharing with us all the information.
The Search Appliances really look nice.
>> JIM: Oh, yeah.
>> MANGTANI: Yeah, data center. I like the--I
like the look of itself. And so, thank you
for showing and thanks for coming. I'm going
to show you one last demo before we open up
for Q&As. Since we talked a lot about APIs,
I just want to show you an end user experience.
This is actually a live site. So you can try
it. This is powered by Search Appliance reuters.com.
This is, you know, as you can understand.
It's a--it's a pretty popular site. And they
get a lot of queries. You can enter any query
here, for example, Goog--Google, short from
Google. What you seen here, they're used in
many of our features, which I have been mentioning
to you. For example, this quote here, this
is a OneBox. So what they are doing is they
are doing a special call to get the results
about the Google's stock loading price, everything
below it here. These are the standard results,
which are coming from the search appliance
and then there are also many--kind of the
results from different avenues, such as video
results and things like that. So as you can
see from this--this live implementation of
the Google Search Appliance, you can practically
customize the UI as you want. It doesn't need
to be necessarily just the top 10 search results.
You can integrate with your backend systems.
You can decide what other information sources
you want to bring in? And you can render the
UI based on how your website looks like. And
obviously, you know, with Reuters, it's a
pretty high kind of quality volume websites
so that having a GSA, which powers them, kind
of makes it easier for them that they don't
need to worry about scaling things like that,
because the Search Appliance can meet their
demands on QPS and things like that. So, again,
a live site, you guys are welcome to play
with it and see some of the cool features
these guys have developed. So with that, I
think we have about 10 minutes or so. Now,
we're going to open it to for Q&A and I have
some passes here. Somebody passed me. There's
a--is a Google enterprise, it says "Invitation
only. Dinner starting at 5:00." So what I'm
going to do is anybody who has an interesting
question--no, actually anybody who ask the
question will give these passes out. So if
you have any question, please feel free to
grab one of those mics. And I don't need to
bribe you with the pass but still...
>> Unfortunately, I have dinner plans. On
the SPI front, I have a concept repository.
It is not one of the ones that you've listed
there. And I want to talk to you about that
later. But do I need to authenticate or verify
user account, and has privileges for every
search result. So in other words, if I issue
a query against the repository and the user
is only entitled to see 10 out of, say, 100
matching results. Do I need to match--do I
need to verify each of those or can I pre-populate
the axis control lists into the index so the
index does the filtering for me.
>> MANGTANI: Yeah, so authentication is--first
of all, so the question is "Do I need to do
multiple time-out indications and what happens
for authorization?" So authentication is only
done once during this session, which is the
browser session or whatever. You can set up
your quick key expiration. As well as the
authorization is concerned, what we do is
we give you an API. And what we have done
for the connectors that weed out, for example,
Documentum, we'd only make one request at
a time. We're literally writing a DQL query.
So we're doing a DQL query right into the
Documentum database sending the identity of
the user, which can be an--LDAP identity with
the records and then trying to get the answer
back from the repository. So it's a very efficient
single call we are doing. We're not storing
any ECLs right now in the Search Appliance,
but the call itself is very efficient and
it is a single call to you back in the repository.
>> Okay, so I have to follow-up.
>> MANGTANI: Sure.
>> So the embed0--in the case of Documentum,
you're doing a live query against Documentum.
So you're letting Documentum's index answer
in respond, not your search index.
>> MANGTANI: Yeah, we are letting the Documentum's
ECL store to be just precise--respond that
have--that have, the user has authorization
or not. That's right.
>> Okay, so. I still need to understand because,
once again, I issue a query, right? Normally,
it would be the Search Appliance who would
basically say, "Okay, I found 10 matching
documents." But if I need to do that reconciliation
between these--the GSA results and the Documentum
results, I need to--well, do some kind of
follow-up query. So you do one full DQL query
and that basically returns the documents that
they get access to? Is that...
>> MANGTANI: We do one full DQL query at the
serve time. Not so...indexing time.
>> At indexing time.
>> MANGTANI: Not indexing out. In a short
time we do one DQL query to find out which
documents do they use at the DQL. And the
benefit of that model is if your Documentum
ECL is changed, we are not storing anything.
We are basically asking the DQL ECL storing
and say what is it unloading?
>> Yeah, so those DQL query also include then
all the--basically all the results that matched
from the GSA front?
>> MANGTANI: Generally, we don't put all the
results because you might have a thousand
results matched. But if any of us are going
to display 15.
>> Let's say a hundred.
>> MANGTANI: So, we'll do only 15.
>> Fifteen, okay. So you sent 15 at that time.
You say, "I matched 15 of these 15 which--which
are--is the user allowed to access."
>> MANGTANI: Exactly. And did you have a pass,
it's here.
>> I have plans.
>> MANGTANI: Okay. He has--he has other plans
for dinner. Maybe we can join you. Okay, go
ahead.
>> I'll take the extra.
>> MANGTANI: Okay. I'll let David distribute
these if you don't mind.
>> A lot of the features you--you have been
talking about today, I know are directly aimed
at the larger Search Appliance. Are any of
these features also included on the Mini side
of things? I mean, I've work with both of
the larger Search Appliance and then the small
and Mini and I'm very interested because on
some of the things that we've had much smaller
repositories but still we'd love to be able
to take advantage of things like the OneBox.
>> MANGTANI: Yeah, so that's a good question.
We actually do support OneBox and Mini. Not
all the features that I spoke today would
support on Mini and the reason is pretty simple
and straightforward. The Mini custom was traditionally,
what we call it, you know, small to midsize
customers. So, you know, we don't want to
put too much complexity in Mini, because it
just makes life difficult. But lots of those
customers don't have the developers skill
set and resources. The things which are relatively
easy like OneBox is actually not that difficult,
so it's available--we do support authentication
with NTLM and LDAP, we don't support connectors
on Mini. So, there's actually a page on the
Google enterprise site, where you can get
the list of features that we support on Mini
or not. And generally our kind of guiding
principle is based on the target audience
that we are going after or who are buying
these products, does this feature make sense
or not?
>> Excellent, thank you.
>> So, we're in possession of a GSA appliance
and we are trying to implement it and we have
to see our end system, Microsoft Dynamics
and so like all the activities, and all our
sales; people enter in are stored on like
a website and when they open up this website,
it actually opens the activities within an
IFrame on this website. So, I was wondering,
is there anyway, like, crawl a content on
the website and the IFrame inside it as well?
>> MANGTANI: So, most of them, it literally
depends; if for some reason we cannot crawl
your content because of JavaScript interprets
it as kind of an inside some complex ministered
IFrame.
>> Yeah.
>> MANGTANI: There are two ways you can solve
that problem: one is, you know, you can explicitly
feed us the raw content itself. So feed the
API, it kind of allows you to do that, right?
The second thing is we can just try it out
and you know, and just feed us the URL. So,
the thing you need to just quickly look at
it, is that, is the search appliance able
to discover the URL? So, that's the first
thing. If it's not able to discover, then
the best thing is, just feed the URL, for
that, at least it should able to discover.
But if it's able to discover and not crawl
the content, then your best option is to push
the content itself as a Base64 and create
content in the Search Appliance.
>> Right, so we tried using the P Protocol,
but for the P Protocol, do you have to use
like a Chrome script to kind of like push
it on a daily basis or how do you kind of
automate the pushing process?
>> MANGTANI: So, does the script--so, feed
us kind of, suggest for the broader audience.
Feed the APIs if ever you can push the content
explicitly in the search appliance. And that
API, you know, we launched it in Search Appliance
around with four others, it's been there out
for three or maybe three and half years. The
new protocol that we launched is this connector
framework. This is kind of more of a full
traversal based protocol and that one gives
you the tools to set up schedule and things
like that. The PDPA is a more kind of a raw
tool kit API. It doesn't have this framework
to set up schedules and admin UI versus the
connector framework that does give you that
entire scheduling and things like that.
>> So would you have to like, set up, like,
some sort Chrome script or?
>> MANGTANI: That's right, if you really like
PDPA using, I would simply like some small
kind of a Chrome, some script that just kicks
off every--to allows it on whatever time.
>> Okay, great, thanks.
>> MANGTANI: Cool.
>> I miss the initial part of this session,
but my question is, in terms of searching
a rich marketing media like Flash, Content
for a specific search term, where does the
approach or towards that kind of searches
and indexes?
>> MANGTANI: So, we do, we do search Flash
to a certain degree and it's getting better.
Actually, we announced our partnership on
main Google, we work with Adobe to help index
the Flash. Because behind the Flash, kind
of the rendering engine, there's the data
model which is the actual data. So, on main
Google we did work with the Adobe team to
actually index the actual data model in data.
We're working with the Adobe team to kind
of make it easier on the Search Appliance
also. For other media types obviously we're
doing a lot of interesting things and this
is kind of the benefit of being under the
Google umbrella. There's still lot of R&D
and this is not a fully solve problem, the
transcripts and videos and indexing and that
stuff. Today, you can obviously if you have
a Meta data for a video: title, author date,
tags; anything, you can push it using any
of our APIs and we'll index them and you can
search it. We don't do any transcription.
There are some third party utilities available
there. To allow you to do transcript and you
can also push it in the Search Appliance.
So, those are the kind of three options for
you to have it manageable.
>> Thank you.
>> MANGTANI: Okay.
>> Well, yeah, are there any plans that expands
on the functionality of bundle on the Search
Appliance and what I'm thinking of is, it
could be more of an alternative or something
like SharePoint, fill in more of the Google
technology around portal apps and all--all
the other things?
>> MANGTANI: So, that's a great question.
The question is, do you guys plan to make
other functionalities as part of Search Appliance,
like Google Apps, and things like that. So,
let me give you a quick introduction of what
Google Apps is, Google Apps is our hosted
platform for document collaboration and document
management, so we have applications like Google
docs, sites, spreadsheets and others. And
we believe, you know, the Cloud gives us a
lot of benefits from scale excess to anywhere--any
device, and that's why we want the leverage
our Cloud computing infrastructure to make
it easier. Now, the Search Appliance, you
know, it's exclusively focused on the content
that's behind the Firewall. So, we don't plan
to make those Cloud computing technologies
in the Search Appliance. We want the Search
Appliance to be the conduit so that it can
search everything that's in the Firewall as
well everything that's in the Cloud. If you
want to use any for--kind of collaborative
tools, I encourage you to sign up for Google
Apps, it's a hosted platform, and it gives
you much better benefits than, you know, to
solve the other collaboration tools out there.
Go ahead.
>> My question is along that Google Apps,
there's a recent article that was out in Fortune
Magazine talking about, you know, white label
in that, so that the enterprise can bring
those applications in--in-house and create
their own application around the base, you
know, calendar, contacts, email; as a part
of the extension, the enterprise solution
within Google and then integrating them into
existing applications within the enterprise.
>> MANGTANI: You know, cheating, asking Apps
question in a GSS session? But luckily I have
a friend of mine, I'm gonna call a friend
of mine, Gabe, do you mind giving a two minute
quick--you can come or you can take the mic.
[pause]
>> GABE: I sense what might be two different
questions, one was white labeling and bringing
the Apps on Primas and other was integrating
them without Prima system. The latter one
is a lot easier to address. The services that
you talked about, the calendar, mail, documents,
et cetera, they have APIs. They basically
allow you to get to and manipulate and control
the data within these applications, either
centrally or driven directly by users. And
you can use those to integrate with on, Prima
system. So, we had a talk today on building
Google, or building applications in the Cloud,
and it was strictly focused on doing document
management through our APIs for those Cloud-managed
documents. Doing integration with like Microsoft
office products directly, doing synch, those
sorts of things? So, that's our vision for
how you do that integration. Is through those
[INDISTINCT] APIs and you can find out more
about those on code site. As for actually
bringing these services in Primas, I think
is--as we mentioned here, that's not something
that's really in the plan, we think that the
strength of those applications is really that
they're offered on the Cloud, that they're
universally accessible. That we can drive
updates, and send these applications in Real
Time, so no plans along these lines.
>> MANGTANI: Thank you, thanks, Gab. It's
good to have your friends around. Go ahead.
>> Hi, you talked about the data biasing features
which I don't know if I understand entirely,
I haven't heard about them before, but I'm
wondering whether it's possible to base the
identity of the user on external data sources
like LDAP?
>> MANGTANI: You could, so there are two kind
of--in some ways there are two distinct features.
One is the biasing feature in itself. [pause]
Okay, we're back in--back in business. So
the question was, what are the biasing features
and how does it relate to personalization.
So, the biasing feature basically allows you
to say, I want to give higher importance to
search results that come from this particular
Wiki or a FileShare or a website. So that's
the example of a biasing feature. Where you
can give importance to a specific subset of
your documents and that can be based on a
URL pattern, Meta data, date or some other
medium. There's a second feature of which
you can create this biasing (ph) features,
instead of for the entire appliance one set
of rules. You can create multiple policies
and then you can think about that each policy
set can be tied to a different LDAP group.
You can create a policy set for engineering
LDAP group, one policy set for marketing,
and one for sales and kind of deliver a different
personalized search experience based on their
LDAP IDs. So, the short answer is yes, you
can type it to your LDAP IDs the BOS piracy
policies. Go ahead.
>> One of the things that we're exploring
is combining kind of traditional document
Centric search with Semantic search. Example
would be, I'm a utility company, I want to
know all of my transformers that are within
two weeks of needing service. So, assuming
that we can deal with the connectivity through--well,
OneBox approach or connector approach, what's
the best way to introduce different kinds
of language or keywords semantics into the
search process? Would you recommend the best
practice for that?
>> MANGTANI: Don't do anything, but I guess
the question is, you know, I--generally I'm
not a big fan of doing a lot of manual tagging
and taxonomy, so--if that's what your question
is inclining, my answer is don't waste your
time. The reason you are paying money to search
renderers in providing the technologies is
that the algorithms should do the job, right?
If you have to tag every single document and
put Meta tags and taxonomy, you can actually
use the open source data base, you don't need
a search engine. The real benefit of having
a true search engine, is this algorithms which
can find the right information, looking at
query and looking at the raw text of the document
and actually, technology has become reasonably
advanced, you know, in the--maybe ten years
ago, I know, a lot of the search renderer
strongly recommended tagging and taxonomy,
it's no longer required. So, my recommendation
is don't invest time on them.
>> Let me kind of follow up with that, is
the difference is, it's not really a match
or a keyword; it's a relation. So, it's, you
know, less than--almost sequel like, kinds
of things to be represented that the search
requires. And again, I'm just curious as to
what is the best practice
>> MANGTANI: Yeah, no, no, so, you know, one
thing, I'll do a quick demo here on Google
for example, and this is something again,
we do it on the Search Appliance also. I enter
a query, Samuel Security and at the bottom
of it, you know, it says, search is related
to Samuel Security. Samuel Soap Binding Liberty
Alliance, Samuel Token, or if I did some of
the search for example, let say, just security.
You know, in the bottom of this thing, it
will give you various related options, you
know, and you can able to look at book search
for those, or if you can enter a more generic
query like cars and it'd give you various
option. So, the technology is already there,
where we can look at the query, we can look
at your results set and automatically give
you suggestions for related queries. And the
same thing features are available on SearchPlants
it's called results clustering, it's called
Dynamic Results Clustering, where we can cluster
these search results and give you the related
terms and suggestions. So, I think we are
almost out of time, if any--then last questions,
I'm happy to take, otherwise, I'm gonna be
outside and will be hanging around there.
Any last questions? I guess not. So, well,
thank you so much for coming and it's great
talking to you guys and thank you for bringing
those questions.